medium here the first Speaker
the minister of France for economy
Finance industrial and digital
sovereignty thank you very much as a
second speaker we have the chair of the
council the one who has worked a lot in
getting everybody together and at least
man she's a federal government
coordinator for space activities in
Germany please
and then of course all director General
Joseph ashbaha who's been leading this
discussion with the executive and will
have the announcement for the cm22 so
without waiting any further and sorry
for the delay there's a lot of numbering
crushing so that you can have the
accurate results of this meeting I would
like to hand over to you Mr minister
thank you and if you allow me I will
speak in French because we we are in
Paris
so I will switch from English to French
so for
all those who do not speak French I
think you have the microphones
the first thing that I would like to say
is that conference is concluding with a
great success beyond our expectations
and I'd like to thank the director
general of Issa Joseph ashbacher who has
left no stone unturned in achieving this
and I think that we can give him a round
of applause to Joseph ashbaker for the
work that he has done
particularly last night
why is this a success that goes beyond
our expectations well because today
Europe can meet the uh it's space
Ambitions fulfill its space Ambitions
Europe has given itself the funds
and Technical scientific and Financial
resources so that it can
compete with China and the US the other
two space powers on the planet so
there'll be three space powers
setting out our Ambitions for space the
U.S China and Europe who have set out
its space ambition today it's Europe has
set out the political resources it needs
by
dating it once it has a preference for
European launchers to launch its
satellites so Aryan and Vega and that
Europe prefers them over other launches
if we want that launch of sovereignty
then we are going to have to assert that
preference for European launchers in
Europe
I'd like to thank
the German Minister for space
and the Italian Minister for space who I
have met at length this morning our
discussions were Lively as they usually
are in Europe but as should always be
the case in Europe we concluded those
discussions by a European agreement
between Germany Italy and France and the
other member states and so I thank you
from the bottom of my heart because
without that constructive approach and
from Robert Harbor as well we wouldn't
have managed to agree on the political
resources to go into this and then of
course the financial resources
um money is what it all comes down to we
know and that's certainly the case for
space Affair we've got almost 17 billion
Euro that will go to the European Space
Agency today and all of that 17 billion
France will contribute 3.2 billion Euro
together with the other Financial
commitments to space
policy
will represent 9 9 billion Euro for
France in the next three years and that
makes France the largest funder of space
activities in Europe
I'd like also to confirm that we will be
putting up to 300 million euro towards
the European constellation the
collective constellation which could
give us communication uh sovereignty as
well
so that's another important step towards
meeting our Ambitions for space
and then scientific resources to go with
the funding and the political will
together with our sovereignty and space
what do we get we get the opportunity to
observe to observe the climate to
observe wind patterns to observe CO2
emissions to see who is emitting and
polluting and who's not and who is
meeting their CO2 emission goals and not
and who is not meeting their goals it
allows us also to monitor climate change
independently and sovereignly and that
is so important for all of us that we're
not going to delegate our the
observation of our CO2 emissions or
Theirs to the US or to China
we want to be able to monitor CO2
emissions around the planet so that we
can adapt energy use and succeed in our
fights against climate change
scientific resources now
communicating communicating on a
day-to-day basis we have some very high
performance systems in Europe
but we would like in Europe to be able
to communicate at a strategic level so
militarily and
on an independent basis
we know that there is a war going on in
Ukraine and that secure Communications
and Military Communications are a
military Affair a strategic Affair and
that if Europe cannot be an independent
power if it delegates its military
Communications to any other power so the
political and scientific resources have
to go towards space and we've done that
and then let me turn now to exploration
I know that this is something that
Thomas peske is very keen on this he'd
like to be the first person on Mars I
don't know if he'll manage but there are
other planets perhaps that might come
into question
I know your Ambitions and your dreams
and I'll share them with everyone
or perhaps we'll have to focus on
achieving other dreams but we want to go
as far as we can in Exploration so that
we can understand the universe that we
live in
understanding is essential for Europe
it's essential for Humanity that's what
we're going to achieve thanks to the
success that this Esa conference has
been Joseph we began in concern but we
wrap up enthusiastic so Vive uh space
policy in Europe and Vive the European
Space Agency thank you Joseph yes
thank you very much for those words of
encouragement pass the floor to an
artist manager of the council and
ministerial level
thank you so much and thanks to our host
uh Bruno mayor thank you for hosting
this ministerial conference here in
Paris that was just magnificent I think
we here at a brilliant venue to talk and
decide about our Ambitions in space so
thank you to France also for the
presidency together with Portugal for
the either over the last three years and
also my thanks of course go to the
director General Joseph ashbera who
prepared with this whole team this
ministerial conference and made us
propositions as member states how we
really can be ambitious in space in
Europe
and I think that is what the Mysterio
meeting has shown and what the member
state has this have decided is Europe is
ambitious in space and I think that is a
very important signal that is sent here
from Paris because space is a very
relevant technology for the future it is
critical infrastructure for many things
that are important for our life on Earth
for saving our planet for having secure
connectivity and having cyber security
and being a sovereign continent and
therefore I'm delighted that we have a
very good result at this conference and
we show this clear signal that we want
to be a strong part in the global
development for space technology and we
are a sovereign continent to develop
these Technologies here in Europe
together and we are also a strong part
partner for our International partners
because that is also a strong sign we
sent here from Paris we do our part in
ambitious missions as Artemis as a new
way to the moon and we as Europe are
part of this and we are an important
partner for the others and especially
the US in this case for going to the
Moon
and sharing this meeting and for me was
really an honor because we had a very
joint spirit that was developing over
the last two days and really decide what
is needed to do go this ambitious path
and we've seen very engaged discussions
to the last minutes and I think that was
really important because everyone was
encouraged and everyone was engaged in
really making this result possible and
there I really want to thank all the
member states I think we have shown what
really European ambition is and what it
means to really
um collaborate together for making these
efforts possible and so I think that is
a strong sector and it shows what Europe
can achieve together
and maybe saying a word about either and
how it is so special how we collaborate
as member states in the context of
either in Europe I think we have with
either a great organizations that offers
us lots of expertise that makes all the
important projects possible and in
Europe sometimes we might discuss a
little bit deeper among all states to
find a solution but then we show here
it's a meeting it's a very
strong result and it's something where
we really come together and bring all
our strengths from the different member
states together from our industry from
our expertise from our science and
research and that together forms just a
very strong continent for space for
expertise for a strong ecosystem and I
think that is something we can be really
proud of as Europeans
[Applause]
so as Joseph Asperger will present the
concrete results in a minute I just want
to say that I think we have really very
important projects in this program that
we decided we as Europe are a strong
actor especially in Earth observation we
really
um have climate as one of our top
priorities that is globally seen that we
have a special expertise in this field
but of course all the other fields we
have a strong program and exploration
and also space safety things that are
also important for sustainability and of
course all the Ambitions that we put now
also in Secure connectivity and being a
sovereign continent so I think we have
great results it was an honor to chair
this meeting and it is an honor for
Germany to have the presidency for the
easer for the next three years and we
are happy together with the member
states together it was easy to like make
uh go this process the next years and
making the efforts to really stay and be
also in future ambitious in space thank
you
[Applause]
thank you so much Madam please man thank
you I can see how much you energize the
member states and you energize this room
thank you maybe I can ask you to take
your seat for a bit of information
whatever is going to be present here
which has taken a little time to get the
data and so on will be available on our
website the ISA
vision.int website Plus in addition we
have the possibility to have interviews
after this meeting so floor resource um
Joseph thank you
so thank you thank you everyone for
these wonderful words first of all
Minister
thank you for having us here this is
such an incredible place here it is a
magic place not only here in this
company FMA but also where we have been
last night or the other social events
which we had this has really inspired us
and has helped us coming to the result
which we have and the hospitality of
France was outstanding also in terms of
preparing this event this meeting with
many interactions as you can imagine and
really a very warm thank you for hosting
us and being such a wonderful host here
for this ministerial conference but also
and the Chrisman has done an incredible
job you have seen you have heard first
glimpses of the result in sharing this
meeting and this is not an easy exercise
I can tell you because there is a lot
going on at the meeting around the
meeting behind the meeting in closed
doors in open doors so there's a lot of
negotiation and this is very specific
for the ISA ministerial conference it is
not the classical conference as you
might imagine it is really that the
member states are negotiating deciding
and subscribing to those programs which
are there priority strategically and
there's a lot of deals made between
member states between different
constellations of member states I'd have
to say this is the beauty of Esa how it
works that we make sure that we provide
the floor and the mechanism that these
programs can be put together and this is
really all the credit going to the
member states who have worked intensely
over the last two days but not only the
last two days actually a year and a half
we have prepared this minister a
conference but of course all culminated
in yesterday and today when all the
programs have been put on the table
subscriptions made subscriptions taken
out again and then somewhere else you
know to make sure that all the
priorities are well met the result is
good and I would like to show you in a
couple of slides what the figures are
and what they are 16.9 billion so close
to 17 billion and this is something
which is quite remarkable and I really
would like to say that this is a large
increase almost 17 percent compared to
the previous ministerial conference so
this is a very significant increase but
you have to see this figure in context
today we have a financial crisis we have
inflation we have an energy crisis we
have of course uh still a situation in
the economy coming out of covet which is
still a challenge for many and despite
these circumstances with inflation being
so high I have to say that I'm very
impressed very impressed by this figure
which has been achieved overall and this
is very significant and this is really
the work of all the member states your
ministers your head of delegations back
in the member states who have I know
worked extremely hard to convince your
finance minister or your head of state
that this is necessary to bring Europe
forward in order to really not only not
miss the train but show where we are
leading and where we are good and you
see here the breakdown of these various
activities
human and robotic exploration plus 16
2.7 billion is a significant increase
compared to about roughly 2 billion
which were last time but much more
important what is in this uh what is the
contender than the money first of all we
Europe are meeting all our obligations
of our International partners one of
them is the ISS operation I can very
proudly and very happily say on behalf
of the member states that we can we can
contribute our part to the operation of
the ISS from the European side and I
think this is a very significant
achievement of this result today that
the ministers collectively have decided
that Europe is committed to the ISS
until 2030 of course together with all
the other space all the other partners
on the ISS and I think this is a
remarkable and I'm very happy to see
that but more than that we have also
committed to other activities in
Exploration
very important we are starting two very
important missions one is what we call
el3 the European large logistic lender
also called algonaut which is a very
large as the name indicates logistic
lender where we are transporting Mass
from the Earth to the Moon
but 1.5 to 1.7 tons to the Moon we will
start work very soon with building up
the various activities the plan is in
the very early 30s to have the first
transport to the moon but what is even
more important is this is not a one-off
mission this is something where we
expect that more of these transports
will be necessary or will be coming up
in the future and therefore this is also
commercially very interesting because
commercial Partners can engage with us
of course through Easter we are
developing the technology we developed
the first I'm going out but then we do
hope that industry in a partnership will
engage and sell some of the transports
to other partners whether they are
institutional or commercial and this is
certainly something that is on the
horizon and today you Minister sir you
have decided that this is one of the
elements in the future
another important element in the
exploration package is Xmas Xmas and
some of you have followed it very
closely has been having a turbulent time
if I may call it this way through the
invasion of Russia and Ukraine we had
immediately to stop the cooperation with
Russia we have terminated formally and
then of course the question is how do we
proceed with this Mission and there were
really different options that have been
discussed all all the way from putting
the Rosalind Franklin robodue museum
until other options which we have been
contemplating with our member states
I'm very glad to say that we have found
a very positive way forward meaning that
Europe will take responsibility the
majority of this mission eczema's
mission will be done with European
technology we work also with our
American friends and they have they have
indicated that they might contribute and
there should be very precise that their
contribution of course still needs to be
confirmed because they have waited for
our decision today but we have
expectation that the U.S is also
contributing through this through a
launcher through the braking engine and
the average UD radioisotope heater units
which are quite important elements but
the majority of the future Xmas mission
is European that means we have replaced
those parts which have been Russian with
European partners and as I say with
three three exceptions with our U.S
Partners so I'm very happy personally to
see this happening because if you think
of the science behind to drill with Sir
with the a two meter drill on the
Martian surface go in underneath and see
whether there has been life or there's
still microbic life existing to see what
that there is life out there has been
like a life out there this is the best
way of doing it and this will be unique
science first science or even in the 80
in six years time when the mission is
being launched so this has been an
extremely important achievement there
have been several other quite important
elements included here but all of the
human and robotic exploration part has
to do with exploration including
astronauts and my Minister Lemer was
already mentioning Thomas cave we have
six of our Seven astronauts here with us
you see them in the rows I'm always so
happy to see them it's uh seeing The
Smiling Faces but also these incredible
people which they are not only telling
us how good and what they do in space
but the research they are doing the
experiments they are conducting is quite
unique and help us a lot in daily life
you will see later on we we will have
also prepared the ground for the Next
Generation the next class of astronauts
I don't want to preempt that part but
this certainly is very much connected to
the human and robotic exploration
envelope and therefore having an
increase a significant increase is very
important let me move on to space safety
space safety are several elements I'm
not going into all the details but just
highlight some of them let me pick a
smaller one just to to show also that
this is a very a very a program with a
lot of diversity in orbit servicing this
is uh something where we expect that
future opportunities will come up of a
commercial nature that we are orbiting
or that we help in orbit that satellites
can be extended their lifetime extended
fuel added or any other technology
applied that this is made possible and
there we trust today in the last few
minutes got the significant increase
because this was recognized as a future
Market as a future Evolution where
future business opportunities can
develop and something that has developed
nicely but of course we have vigil with
Hera which are the large missions we
chill for space weather here of course
to make sure that we are in combination
with the doubt mission of the US making
understanding well what happened at the
impact of the NASA Mission then space
transport station space transportation
of course is the core of our business
meaning that we need to make sure that
we can launch our Satellites with
European means and having our launch
capability and there and this server is
already mentioned by Minister Lemaire we
have made huge progress and huge
progress and I'm commenting this a bit
maybe behind the curtain behind the
scenes we have
really managed that the three countries
were the main investors in the launcher
domain Germany France and Italy that
they have signed this paper which you
have managed we have of course only
helped in the process but which you have
signed which was I think a milestone in
moving ahead and launches for me this is
a very important Milestone because I and
this sir I'm saying as director general
of the European Space Agency we are
interested to have European projects
European initiatives and I was afraid
that on the launcher side this European
Spirit has not been as strong as it
should be and this Divergence which
could happen I think we have brought
together again and this is really thanks
to the politicians who have made very
clear directions given very clear
guidelines on what and how we do it and
really this was so important so
important for launchers but also of all
the other doses because launchers
obviously is connected to many other
doses so this was really an important
Milestone so there we have four main
activities Within space transportation
of course the use of Aryan 6 and Vega in
the future are making sure that the
exploitation is very well on its feet
and the subscriptions have been very
very good you see overall plus 17
percent
we have also spacewriter it's a very
important reusable vehicle which we are
building up and this is a letter by
Italy but of course with other partners
and this is something that is extremely
important as technology with development
for Europe we have Boost which is
developing into future Technologies or
future technology is also supporting
micro launches for example and there we
have also got good subscription and of
course very very important the use of
the Spaceport and the space
infrastructure of Kuru but also some of
the other facilities
Thanos observation Earth observation has
a long list of individual projects of
course the biggest one being future Rio
of course I know this uh program very
well having been there myself for a
couple of years but uh this future you
really prepares the ground for all the
other Earth observation activities but
we also have concrete missions we have a
new Earth Explorer we have ils2 ilos is
a mission where
technology is used which nobody in the
world has mastered yet that means a UV
laser to measure wind profiles in
cloud-free atmospheres nobody else has
mastered this technology Europe has done
it with alos one and now we build an
operational Mission together with
humansad to make this happen
plus of course the number of other
satellites in cubed and other programs
within which in the earth observation
package are extremely essential to
address the fundamental fear of many
young people which is climate change and
we have to respond to this and space can
really respond telecommunications and
integral applications as a number of
activities but let me again highlight
some of course artists the artist
program is developing technology for all
Telecom activities so it's a very
industry driven or partnership oriented
project where industry quite often makes
the proposal with us we develop
technology in order to make sure
industry is very competitive and this is
a very successful and the result of
course is that European space industry
and telecoms are really really
competitive on the World Market but also
we have and this is extremely important
for me personally and I think for many
of you we have funded or we are funding
secure connectivity co-funding and
implementing activities which is the
program led by the European Union I
think this is a very important aspect
not only for the content that means we
build up a European constellation
but also the partnership with the
European Union and our partners of
course the initiative being led by uh
commissioner breto but there I think we
have now put money on the table through
these member State mechanism and we help
developing building up this program and
I think it is fair to say that the
contributions of these member states
have been essential for this program to
really take off and gain momentum and
gain further weight of course in a very
close cooperation with commissioner
Bretton who gave a fantastic speech
yesterday in these ministerial Council
addressing the importance of secure
connectivity for Europe and for all of
us and I'm very proud that we have
delivered that you ministers have
delivered the the Easter portion of it
is a part of it that goes together but
also we have civil security from space
as one of the elements included in the
package of Tia but also moonlight
moonlight being a future constellation
of Telecom and navigation satellites on
on and around the Moon that means the
constellation of course around the moon
but for use on and around the moon this
is something where I see huge commercial
potential as well because communication
as you have mobile phones here you pay a
price for your phone calls also in the
future on the moon there will be
communication needs and there will be
commercial activities and there's a
strong Commercial Drive here as well
technology
needless to say that especially in times
of Crisis like we have them today with
the war in front of our door you need to
be more autonomous you need to make sure
that you have more Independence in terms
of Technology not only from Russia but
in general that Europe has a strong
space capability and in technology we
are developing this strong space
capability thanks to the subscription
sir which have come today one of the
elements I'd like probably to pick out
within this secretary Solaris Solaris is
a feasibility study I'm not saying this
is yet the project it's a feasibility
study which will see how far or what the
hurdles are from a technology point of
view in order to gain uh electric photo
again solar power in space beam it down
to the surface and of course then use
this energy on the surface if this works
and if we could establish
a solar power plant in space and the
Order of gigawatts this is the order of
magnitude we are aiming at and use this
uh sustainably on the ground this would
be a huge game changer but as I say I'm
still careful there because we're first
to test technology viability but this
has huge potential if it works
commercialization we have a relatively
small envelope here called scale up it
was over subscribed as you see which I
think there's something wrong with the
numbers so that my recollection is 17 or
20 percent oversubscribed uh it is all
one so it's one percent of durable
budget but there was more uh budget than
I was originally planned the envelope is
100 million and I think this is uh
showing that the commercialization drive
is working and Europe is engaging in
this and certainly something where we
want to create new opportunities for
businesses and other activities
basic activities is really basic
activities that means infrastructure
technology development there are many
facility activities also I.T
communication this type of activities
which are covered in this part you see
here the amounts of money which has been
which have been provided and last but
not least the scientific program which
is also part of the so-called mandatory
program or level of resources which here
is at 3.1 billion uh making 19 of the
world budget science program of course
looking into the universe and different
missions that explore the very nature of
our universe of our of our being and
therefore very well and very important
and products which goes together with
the science program let me move on and
show you some of detailed figures per
program as you see them here in
comparison with 2019 I'm not going into
them now one by one I think the table is
very self-explanatory we will published
these figures of course widely so you
can see your own assessment and you see
that in some domains the increase was a
bit higher than in other ones but this
overall I think is very very successful
and it's a very positive message which
we can carry with us here back from
Paris
this is a
listing of these subscriptions per
country
again I'm not going into detail here
because this is uh I think for deeper
analysis and each country of course is
standing a bit looking into more details
but if you look at the at the right hand
side you see the share of the
contributors but I also what what I also
would like to say is that almost every
country had a significant increase of
its budget this year compared to last
time and as I said at the beginning this
is so remarkable and this is so special
and this is something that you cannot
overestimate how important this is given
the current circumstances
last but not least just one word to say
that of course the income from our
member states in Issa is the fundamental
part you are the shareholders of visa
and you are funding the majority but I I
would like to mention for the sake of of
being complete in our budget description
that we also have very important
cooperations with third parties uh other
partners with whom we cooperate since a
long time of course the European Union
we've signed the ffpa last year more
than 9 billion around 9 billion euros
for the time frame 21 to 27 is a
technology assistance to Italy to Greece
and to Spain as you see here we have
recently signed very significant
agreements here all together adding up
to almost uh two billion uh Euros a bit
less than 2 billion but just to say that
also here we have cooperation agreements
with some of the countries which are
using these mechanism in order to
implement projects also of course I
needed what I need to mention here is
that we have long-standing agreements
cooperation agreements with umizat for
the development of all meteorological
missions and there we also come to
agreements and sign agreements as New
Missions are being approved on the side
of umizat but the ones you see here are
the ones that have been signed last year
and this year so ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much this is a big relief
all of us thank you ministers thank you
all of you for this strong contribution
thank you very much Joseph
before we go into the Q a I would like
to invite vanilla mayor and an artist
man to join Joseph on stage and will be
able to take a few questions from the
audience please state your name and the
media you're working for and raise your
hand so we have microphone going on so
I'm taking a question here over there
Aviation week question for yourself do
you have all the money you need for
Aryan 6 especially the block 2 and the
transition phase
uh yes we do I may ask maybe for the
help of Daniel he's who is in the
audience so if there's a very detailed
question on this particular elements but
Daniel very briefly announcer from your
side thank you
yes good morning to all the answers yes
for the transition program we are uh
even a little bit above what we expected
so this is excellent news for the year
23 to 25 and on the product adaptations
meaning for Block two we are on a very
good path to do it
okay political yes
hi I'm Joshua Persona from Politico two
quick questions first of all to director
general actually backer did any non-eu
countries uh commit money to the secure
connectivity scheme and then also to
minister Lemire this is more a question
for the future but you did not have
substantive talks today or funding talks
on any human space flight program this
seems as Mission critical for the French
government in the future is this a
regret that you weren't able to talk
about this uh properly this time around
non-eo countries did they commit I would
need to look into the long table of many
pages of details but yes they did I
don't know the exact numbers but these
numbers can be published
foreign
we did have the discussions on all
subjects I can set your mind at rest on
that so all of the French options were
taken into consideration during this
meeting
uh Peter's selling space in teleport for
Joseph Verano one of your delegations
and not the least of them said that the
secure connectivity project was an
existential test for ESA
that's a strong word in French or in
English
um I'm not sure I understand why it's
such a big test is your participation in
this now going to mean Esa changing its
rules to put them more in conformance
with what the EU commission does
if not I don't I'm not sure what's so
existential
important
contribution in this program but it is
for us clear this one is an easy program
where we signed as member states of Isa
and then it will kind of be part of the
connectivity initiative but to the rules
of the easer so it's uh that is
important so that member states will be
included in the program and will be
involved and further decisions on these
part of the programs
thank you next question
yes
Jeff
bounce the space news for director
General I know you were asking for
something on the order of 18.5 billion
so something had to fall short to get to
16.9 billion our programs being
curtailed or programs not being funded
at all as a result of that shortfall
good no thank you I can be very very
short on this answer nothing has had
been curtailed uh some of it had been of
course uh reduced and slightly in scope
so what happens typically is if there is
a an under subscription on the program
and this is not the first time I can
tell you this is actually uh happening
uh normally what we do is we go back to
the member states and we say look we
have asked for 100 we've got 93 so what
do we do with 93 and Define this in work
plans or they are decided by the member
states on how we proceed forward this
will be done for all the budget lines uh
this is standard process standard
procedure as we do it uh every time
after ministerial conference but nothing
had to be deleted or taken out of the
portfolio
thank you question over there
so you have decided to launch exomers
with the European Technologies of
congratulations for that but what does
it mean in terms of the schedule you
have a calendar for the examiners now uh
the schedule is the one we have
published or announced some time ago the
launcher is so yes sorry the launch is
planned for 2028.
thank you Jonathan BBC
thank you you had some difficulty in
future EO and I wonder what this means
uh for that program and particular
aspects of it the harmony Mission uh for
example Earth explorers future gravity
cooperation with the United States
um are we on the back foot now on on
those missions
okay what will happen on future Rio and
simonetta Kelly is with us we can give
maybe more details but uh what we will
do is of course as I said before we will
go back to the member states and say
look we have got this amount instead of
that amount we need to make a decision
how to move forward and this is again
standard procedure I've done it myself
in the past when uh I was in charge of
first observation and then yes sir you
have to see what may not be done at the
same scale as was planned before uh
certainly but I don't want to first of
all preempt any of these decisions
because this will be done by the member
states and the proposals have now to be
elaborated or of course looking at the
subscriptions uh the amount that I can
tell you there will be many scenarios
drawn up to make sure that we have the
best possible scenario for the member
states but maybe somebody that they want
to say can you stand up please
Jonathan thank you yeah well can be said
it's that overall the yo domain has got
a strong Support futurio also with the
level of funding which uh we have to
check still the figures but goes of the
order of 80 percent uh what needs to be
done this is an envelope program so it
has various components what needs to be
done is exactly what the director
General has said now to go back to
member states we will do this between
December and February work a world plan
over the next three years of what can be
implemented what are the Strategic
priorities and these of course include
missions like Harmony that you just
mentioned the gravity missions or the
Scout Mission and the decisions of what
needs to go ahead how fast and when will
be taken with member states
thank you I take one last question and
then we move on with the program if none
yes the meter yes maybe somebody else
who wasn't okay Peter go ahead you have
you won
thanks for the endorsement Phillip um uh
Joseph
if I understood Jerry button's speech
yesterday
it shouldn't be possible for non-eu
members to take part in this uh the
secure connectivity program even at Issa
he doesn't want non-eu components or
contractors ventilating into a system
that ultimately goes to Brussels even if
Esa start has its own separate financing
round so could you help us explain that
no I did first of all as you probably
know the secure connectivity program is
has two elements and within these
elements different phases so there are
some of the elements that are more for
hardcore uh government uh government
government communication and that
certainly is if I may say earmark that
the EU member states but there are other
elements and especially those on the
more on the commercial side or more open
site where this system will be much more
wider open so this is all a worker that
is being defined but let me say that
this process has to be developed
together with the commission through the
concessionaire which will be built up
through also the announcements which
come out from the commission next year
and of course the announcements on our
side for the esa money which means the
subscriptions of Visa member states The
Ether rules will apply and of course
these are member states will be involved
in this decision making we also go to
IPC for example if that is not too much
detail on some of the decisions that
need to be made
thank you very much for let me thank
Bruno marsman and Joseph for this
session I remind you there will be
possibility after the next event to have
one-on-one interviews uh there are some
work uh behind this curtain and like
without any delay to invite you to take
a seat back and launch the second part
for this I would like to
um
share with you a short video so I will
ask the regi to start and launch the
video you'll see on the screen and then
we will proceed with the announcement of
the new class 2022. thank you
I want to build a rocket
[Music]
Stars
[Applause]
I want to
a better Steward of planet Earth
[Music]
I won't defend our own against dangers
from outer space
[Music]
I want to unravel the mysteries of the
universe
and our place within it
[Music]
discoveries with the world
[Music]
to become an astronaut
why not you
[Music]
we woke up at the night sky
foreign
[Music]
space agency
every day
into giant leaves
[Music]
ready to join the crew
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen it's
great to have you here with us at the
ministerial Council
thank you my name is Louise Houghton I
will be guiding you through this next
event and the much awaited announcement
of the 2022 Esa astronaut class whether
you're here with us in Paris or watching
online at home I think you'll all agree
that this is a very exciting time for
the European Space Agency we just heard
the fantastic news that ESET member
states have agreed to fund European
space activities with 17 billion euros I
think that deserves a round of applause
we've seen so many benefits from this
funding in the past and we're excited to
see the ideas for future Esa space
activities come to light the light today
though falls on the next class of Issa
astronauts and we'll be announcing who
they are very shortly
thousands of people submitted an
application for this opportunity and the
selection process started in April of
last year there were many rounds and
then the final hurdle was a detailed
interview with esa's director General I
think that this is the perfect
opportunity to announce who those people
are and who better to help me announce
those names than issa's director General
himself please welcome to the stage
Yosef asbacher
thank you so much for joining me on the
stage thank you so so happy to be here
nice to see you nice to see you
um so what are the top criteria that you
look for when you're selecting an
astronaut
what do we look for first of all these
are incredible people you see some of
the astronauts here in the room and uh I
know them pretty well now and they
really have talents that are quite
incredible I mean they are unique and I
think I really can say that they are
unique in many ways of course you look
for uh the all the intellectual
capability they have all the manual
capabilities that they can make quick
decisions uh under pressure usually and
make sure that they push the right
buttons and not the wrong ones and make
sure that everything goes fine but also
of course we have gone through I would
say a number of steps or tests in
evaluation we had about six big steps
big waves of reducing the 23 almost 23
000 of applications down to a few we
will see them coming up very soon and
there are one of the last hurdles is the
medical test and the very last third
listed like the general officer was that
fun oh that was so much fun I tell you
talking to these people and interviewing
them together of course with some of my
colleagues is is really fun because you
you can drop them of course a bit under
pressure this is what astronauts like
they put them under pressure and see how
they react and whether they have all
they need to be an astronaut they need
to be very special people well we will
announce who they are very shortly but
before we do I'd love to hear a little
bit more about what they're actually
going to be doing once they're appointed
but once they're appointed so of course
first we select them and then I think
there's a huge media frenzy and all the
astronauts and they will be very busy
giving interviews and doing all kind of
interactions but once they are appointed
we have actually two categories of
astronauts one we call career astronaut
and the other one is astronauts in the
reserve pool which is uh let me briefly
explain the career astronauts are the
ones where we immediately give a
contract to them and start working with
them to to have a base training to make
sure that they get all the information
needed but also that they are getting
ready for future missions the space
training will be at the European
astronaut Center in uh in the cologne in
Germany but also in other places and the
last about a year a bit more than a year
and then there would be as I say ready
for a future mission for which they have
to be trained and then once a future
mission is identified of course then the
training for that mission will have to
occur uh the uh the astronauts in the
reserve pool
um astronauts that are astronauts as the
name say so there is no difference there
are astronauts but of course they are
not yet engaged by either directly
through a permanent contract but they
will be available for future astronaut
activities so they usually would
continue their job in what they do so
they would be a physician or a fighter
pilot or we have quite a different
diversity of those so they would
continue their job but we would have an
engagement with them we will give them a
shorter contract so that they work with
us that we can interact with them
regularly and then if opportunities
arise maybe later on of course they can
then be put into full training for
Baseline trainings fast runouts and
future missions and different projects
and different projects well we look
forward to finding out who they are I
don't think we should keep anybody in
suspense any longer do you do you want
to do the honors and lift the curtain
how do
you on your call okay lift a curtain
a big round of applause
[Applause]
wow
lots of smiles that we're seeing here on
the stage this is our 2022 class of Issa
astronauts I I'd like to say some names
and introduce them to you so the first
line from left to right we have Sophie I
don't know
[Applause]
Pablo Alvarez Fernandez
Megan Christian
Anthea komalini
Rosemary Coogan
Sarah Garcia Alonso
Rafael Yeshua
and John mc4
yes if I can see your smile is as big as
theirs how are you feeling right now I
think my smile is even bigger it's uh so
beautiful to see them I have seen them
just a few weeks ago we had the
interview and I'm very happy to see you
again and uh it really makes me think of
all the Brilliance of these people they
have been very sharp in their in their
responses to my difficult questions I
hope you didn't mind too much I did tell
you when uh in the interview that you
may be invited to Paris you may not know
whether you're selected or not but if
you're going to Paris I said you will
only find out whether your career
restaurant
Reserve pool today and this is what
happened so I think this was very much
of attention for you but I thank you for
being so brave and so wonderful yes and
we'll find out who is going to be a
career astronauts in just a moment but
for now I'll introduce the line at the
back we have starting from left again
Andrea patasa
Carmen poznick
Arnold Frost
Emily shonenberg
Marcos diva
suavel it was naninsky
Marcus Vance
and Nicola winter
I'm so happy to introduce each and every
one of you huge congratulations to you
for being at this stage here today
um it's so nice to have you with us and
thank you as well for you joining me on
the stage I'd like to invite you back a
little bit later on if that's okay let
me say one last yes please I mean if you
look at these wonderful people here of
course the selection was about talent
and about capabilities to be a fantastic
astronaut but I'm also very proud that
it happens to be a very good
distribution of genders so we have
almost 50 percent uh ladies in this
group here and I think that's also very
important and from very different
countries so you will find out pretty
soon from which countries they come I
think this is something I'm very happy
about I'm happy about that too thank you
so thank you once again to Joseph
ashbacher
well I would now like to invite to the
stage is director of human and robotic
exploration Dr David Parker
hello hello
thank you for joining me David you are
also involved with the selection of the
astronauts that we see here today and I
know that it was important for you to
make sure that the final selection was
very diverse
um as us have already mentioned we have
50 women here on the stage which is
fantastic to see from my point of view
but I know it was important for you to
include astronauts with a physical
disability yeah this is very important
to us diversity it comes in many
different ways and uh it's the World
Health Organization reckons that about
15 of the population live with some sort
of disability in maybe two percent are
really affected by it and so in of
course to be an astronaut is a very
exclusive thing to be but having a
disability shouldn't rule you out and
that was really part of this very
special project that we launched in this
process and I understand that their name
is going to be called para astronauts do
you want to talk a bit more about where
that name came from yeah absolutely so
para means para as in parallel well or
alongside it's like the Paralympics it's
the parallel process alongside the
Olympic Games and the same way the Paras
Lord has been selected Trey developed uh
examined in every different way in
exactly the same process as all the
other astronauts that you see here well
this is the first time that we are
attempting to fight somebody with a
physical disability to space so I
understand that there's probably quite a
lot of uncharted waters ahead oh yeah
absolutely I mean we are pioneering
something here it's something we're
really excited to be doing we need to
start a process by which we are going to
work with the individual understand how
to adapt the space vehicle maybe
something aboard the space station to
ensure that they can live and work and
do a meaningful mission of all the
station of course and I'd like to invite
them to the stage now I'm going to go
and grab a microphone so that we can
have a few words from them so I think
it's wise that we now announce our para
astronaut for 2022 and that is John
McCall
congratulations John it's great to have
you with us here at the front of the
stage I'd love to ask you a little bit
more about why you applied to be an
astronaut first of all
well when um we need to announce they
were looking for a candidate with a
physical disability
I thought it was such an inspiring uh
and exhilarating opportunity and I
looked at the person's specification and
I thought wow this is this is really
aspirational this is very brave and very
bold thing to do
uh and with my broad scientific
background and vast range of experiences
I felt compelled to try and help itsa uh
answer this question can we get someone
with a physical disability to do
meaningful work in space
so what do you think that you can
contribute to the feasibility study I
think that I can bring lots of things to
the feasibility study but I think in
particular I can bring inspiration you
know inspiration that science is for
everyone
but inspiration that potentially space
is for everyone
okay and do you want to just talk a
little bit more about the feasibility
study David and what it hopes to achieve
well we're really interested to work
with John uh overcome the challenges
that may exist but also benefit the
whole community and reach out and ensure
that they come along the journey with us
in preparing for John to fly
okay great well I'm sure that you have a
lot more to say and that will be said in
interviews later on but for now I would
like to say thank you to both of you
thank you to Dave Parker um issa's
director of human and robotic
explanations it's great to have you with
us on stage thank you so much and John
if you would like to just go and stand
over there on the side of the stage and
we'll announce some of the career
astronauts today thank you so much to do
those announcements though I would like
to invite back to the stage um issa's
director General Joseph ashbaker
thank you
thank you so much for coming back up on
stage now you talked already about the
two different classes or two different
selections that there is here today
either a career astronaut or somebody in
the reserve is there anything more you'd
like to add to that before we announce
the names I mean they are all astronauts
so I really would like to make this
clear that they're all equally capable
of flying to space because because we
have done all the tests and all the all
the pressure we have put on them the
only thing is that uh we have not 20 or
so flight opportunities so we need to
make a choice and start with one badge
and maybe for the others a bit later and
look for other opportunities so yes they
are all astronauts of course with the
career astronauts we start working
immediately that means early next year
or we will offer them a contract or you
have seen the contract already to really
start fully engaging them in all the
base training that is needed and prepare
them for future missions fantastic well
I think it's time that we and announce
our first one then let's come into the
middle of the stage a little bit more as
me and that's our first Easter career
astronaut for 2022 is Sophie I don't
know
[Applause]
congratulations congratulations to you
nice to have you with us um love to hear
a little bit more about yourself your
background and how you came to be here
today
first of all uh good afternoon to each
of you I I understand that you've worked
really hard for the past two days to get
the incredible results that we've seen
just for the antidote we've worked
pretty hard for the past year and a half
to get here on this stage and and I
think we're all very happy to be here so
my background I
I'm a career officer from the French air
and space force I'm a helicopter test
pilot as well as an engineer
I worked at Erebus helicopters to start
with and then I threw a rescue missions
and transport Mission throughout Europe
I have 3 000 flight hours and flew on 22
different helicopter types as a test
pilot
wow
and how confident what are you feeling
in the run-up to today's selection
I'm never confident I mean when you you
realize that there are so many
candidates
if you're away and hoping that the next
step is going to work for you and uh but
now we're very happy okay well
congratulations to Sophie I don't know
please do go and join John over there on
the side of the sink thank you
and it now gives me great pleasure to
announce the second Esa career
astronauts of 2022 is Pablo Alvarez
Fernandez
[Applause]
congratulations congratulations Pablo
I'd love to hear a little bit more about
your background and how you came to
apply to be an astronaut
hello everyone I'm Pablo arvales from
Spain
I'm an art Space Engineer I studied in
the University online in my hometown and
I hold a master degree from the workshop
University of Technology
I'm happy to have lived in several
different countries across Europe so I
truly feel I'm European and hot
um uh up to now I've been working at
Tervis as a structural engineer for
several different aircrafts but also as
the EXO Mars mechanical architect for
the Russell Franklin brother
and now I'm a project manager based in
Madrid
and how was your experience of the final
interview with yourself be very honest
it was excellent it was excellent yeah I
could tell that he was subtly enjoy an
interview in every one of us uh he was
speaking at some point and and he he had
to play the bad cop
uh but overall my experience was great
and I'm very happy and delighted to be
here with you all we're delighted to
have you here as well huge
congratulations to Pablo Alvarez
Fernandez
so you play the bad
just playing the bad College I like
being the bad cop to really put pressure
on them and see whether they really
sustained unless you see the all
survived well
okay well I'm going to quiz you about
that later on let's announce the third
astronaut though for the career
selection today and that is Rosemary
Coogan
congratulations Rosemary
thank you very much yeah would you like
to follow you in the same vein as the
others and tell us a little bit about
your background yeah so my name is Rose
Marie Coogan I'm 31 years old and I'm
European but from the UK
England
I spent a few years as a royal naval
Reserve during my studies
and then went on to work briefly in
industry for software and Robotics
companies before doing a PhD in
astrophysics and I work with the French
space agency Cadets oh fantastic and
what do you look forward to doing the
most in this position
oh well it's I mean as Joseph said the
training will start next year and
already that's going to be a fantastic
experience a survival training the
language learning and I think ether has
put together a really fantastic
exploration program as we've heard about
at the ministerial and I'm really just
looking forward to contributing what I
can to that program okay
you have to thank all these ministers
for preparing the ground yes thanks very
much
and we are a huge congratulations once
again to Rosemary
[Applause]
well we do have a fourth career and
astronaut to announce and I'm happy to
say that that is
Rafael Yeshua
congratulations Raphael thank you all
right well following in the in the same
vein as the others would you like to
give us a little bit more information
about yourself sure so uh good afternoon
everyone it is a pleasure to be here I'm
Rafael uh from Belgium I my background
is in biomedical engineering I also did
a PhD in neuroscience at the University
of liege in Belgium and I completed that
PhD in 2015 and since then I have been
working as a neuroscientist in various
research institutes in Singapore in the
United States and I am now a research
and teaching fellow at the University of
Geneva and at the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology in lausanne in
Switzerland fantastic and you applied
for this opportunity 18 months ago when
you sent in that application did you
just forget about it or did you hear
kind of quite soon on how was the
application process for you
well uh quite long uh that that's the
same for all the candidates I believe so
it was 18 months in total eight uh six
steps so roughly a couple months between
each step so it was hard at times we
were waiting for an answer that was not
coming so that was hard for us but also
hard for the families that I would like
to thank also for supporting us and
dealing with us when we were in these
situations but overall it was a very
great experience okay well
congratulations to you once again please
put your hands together for Raphael yeah
thank you
congratulations
it must have been a very tough decision
I think to select these career
astronauts it was a very tough decision
I can tell you there have been so many
Fantastic candidates you see them here
but also many others uh and for the ones
who have applied and are not standing
here I really would like to say that I'm
pretty sure you are also wonderful I
hope you engage with these in the future
we have many other good jobs to offer we
would like to really stay in contact
with you because this is something very
important to us but it was a tough
decision I can tell you I mean so well
we do have one more career astronaut to
announce today and that is Marco sieber
[Applause]
congratulations Marco
um love to hear a little bit more about
your background as well please
I'm Marcus from Switzerland I'm 33 years
old and I'm a medical doctor
specialized in emergency medicine and
currently I'm doing a training in
urology sorry and um yeah otherwise I I
like everything that has to do with
flying paragliding skydiving so that's
what I do so you already like being up
in the air yeah that's great to hear
what was the most challenging part of
this selection process for you
um yeah I think it was a really some
kind of a roller coaster with not
knowing what's going to happen next and
so it was really hard and also for uh
really tough questions as well
and also for my family and friends and
my my partner so I would like to thank
everyone for supporting me all the way
thank you very much Mercy well thank you
for being here Marcus sieber everybody
and that does conclude our career
astronaut selection today Joseph it's
been an amazing day for you and the
European Space Agency if you had to sum
it all up in a nutshell what would you
say oh today was quite a day I mean
there was a roller coaster for the
astronauts so not knowing until now what
really happens for me I have to say and
this is for me representing really
Europe and space through the European
Space Agency there are two important
things of course the announcement of the
astronauts here is a highlighter which
is so fantastic but also our ministerial
conference I have to say was quite quite
an important emotional moment as well
putting all this together the food
Surfer a year and a half worker
wonderful programs which we are starting
now with this uh commitment of Our
member states and I think seeing that
Esa is really working extremely well
thanks to all the member states and all
these contributions is so beautiful to
see and really thank you for that from
my side once more
thank you and we look forward to hearing
how it all unravels as the years and
months go on um I know you already said
some thanks but I would also like to
thank you for being on stage and helping
me out here today and I'd like to thank
our audience whether you're here with us
in Paris or watching us Online for being
so enthusiastic this afternoon before we
close this afternoon's event though we
would like to have a group photo on
stage with everybody and then the
astronauts and the ministers will be
going into their separate offices for
the interviews we do ask that any of the
journalists here please be patient and
our media team will be coming to collect
you and take you to them one by one for
the group photo then in just a minute
I'd love to invite the class of 2009
astronauts up to the stage as long as
all along with all of the ministers and
Dr David Parker as well and please do
use the steps on either side of the
stage to come up onto the platform my
name is Louise Hayden it has been an
absolute pleasure to host this a
momentous occasion here in Paris today
if you want to keep up to date with
what's going on with our astronauts then
you can do that online at esa.int or of
course on social at issaastro
2022. all right have a great rest of
your afternoon everybody and a safe
journey home thank you very much
[Applause]
please do come on stage with a
photograph everybody
astronauts